aux etats unis s'ouvre aujourd'hui le
premier procès lié aux attentats du 11
septembre 2001 et c'est un français qui
est sur le banc des accusés zacarias
moussaoui 37 ans il a admis sa
complicité avec le commando du 11
septembre mais nie sa participation
pour lui ce sera la mort ou la prison à
vie car inkomazi la sphère états unis
contre moussaoui
c'est le nom donné par la cour de l'état
de virginie au premier procès en lien
direct avec les attentats du 11
septembre
un état contre un homme zacarias
moussaoui arrêté avec un visa périmé en
août 2001 un mois avant les attentats
le français prenait alors des cours de
pilotage la justice américaine l'accuse
d'avoir détenu des informations sont le
complot sans avoir rien fait pour
l'éviter
la justice américaine qui réclame la
peine de mort a baissé en boxer moi je
demandais une justice et que soit on
gagne ou jugé pour les faits qui lui
sont reprochés qu'il a fait mais acariès
moussaoui n'aide pas sa mère ni ses
défenseurs en avril 2005 il plaide
coupable et déclare à la juge être le
20e pirate de l'air un esclave dallas a
recruté par oussama ben laden lui même
l'aveu ne laisse le choix ni à moussa 8
me à ses avocats
il reste que la peine de mort ou dans le
meilleur des cas la prison à vie s'ils
vont essayer de s'en doute dire que
mentalement il est ou psychologiquement
il se trouve dans un état d'inaptitude
est ce que nous demandons la peine de
mort absolument la rancune des familles
américaines
l'enjeu politique de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est un procès sous pression qui débute
aujourd'hui et qui fait craindre à la
défense une parodie de justice
ce serait une très mauvaise affaire pour
le gouvernement américain que de vouloir
à tout prix comme il le prétend obtenir
la condamnation à mort de zacarias
moussaoui et d'en faire lui-même un
martyr c'est zacarias moussaoui était
condamné à mort ce serait une première
dans l'histoire récente des états unis
la peine capitale ne s'applique pas
quelqu'un qui n'a pas directement donné
la mort
et puis